المترجم: Fatima Bamashmoos
المدقّق: Anwar Dafa-Alla
أكل العالم وغص بنخلة
لا ماء هناك لا ماء
من يشرب سمًا من دجلة
من يعرف عُشتار
من يدنو من قصر جني في بابل
من يعرف طريق الذئب يتبع ليلى
ويجلس في نفس السلة
يأخذني الحب إلى بغداد
إلى المنصور إلى هارون
إلى إلى التاريخ
أخاف أن أذكر الأسماء يا بغداد
فإن اسمك يابغداد هو العلة
أكل العالم وغص بنخلة
لايعرف أن الناس هناك
ينامون على السطح
ويفترشون البساتين
وجوههم بالشمس مبتلة.
أكل العالم وغص بنخلة.
لا ماء هناك لا ماء
من يشرب سمًا من دجلة
(تصفيق)
اسمي نسيم الداغستاني
كائن على وجه هذه البسيطة.
ولدت في غرفة مكتبة
بس المكتبة فيها نوافذ
حتى لمن تكبر جناحاتي أقدر أطير
أعتقد البداية مثل طفل حامل بالون أحمر
بس بسبب خفة وزنه أخذه البالون وطار
طار للخيال الآخر
هل يمكن أن يكون بين الخيال والواقع رابط؟
هذا الشيءالأول
الذي بحثت عنه
من كنت طفله أحب التشابه
أريد الأطفال متشابهين
كنت أكذب كثيرًا
وأقول أنني مثل صديقتي
لدي خمس أوست أخوات
أحب التشابه
وصلت مرحلة إلى ألاحظ الأطفال الآخرين
كيف يجلسون؟ كيف يأكلون ؟
كنت مراقبة جيدة
كنت هادئة جدًا
كنت طفلة نحيلة
أمي تحط لي أكل كثيرلأنني طفلة نحيلة
كنت أشاهد الأطفال
في بعضهم يتركون بقايا الطعام على شباك الصف
أعتقد تذكرون هذا الشيء
فكان هناك أطفال خفية يأتون
ويأكلون هذه البقايا
صرت أروح أخذ أكلي لأن هوايه
وما أحب الأكل
وأحطه على الشباك
وبنفس الوقت أقعد أكل وياهم
وبلشت هنا أنا أشوف لا فرق
أكلت أو ما أكلت من أهم الأطفال
المشوار بدأ ورجعت ببالوني الأحمر
هذه المرة كان دخولي لعلم النفس،
علم نفس الإنسان
حاولت من خلال هذا المجال
أن أدرس منو نحنا؟ ماذا سنفعل؟
وهل للإنسان هناك مهمة؟
وكيف يجمع هذه المهمات؟
وهناك هم فردي وهم كوني
لهذا حاولت أكون أكثر واقعية
بعد مشاهدتي هذه الذكريات
بلشت أصير مستشارة للأطفال،
متطوعة بالمخيمات بالشارع
وبدأ هذا المشوار
إلى أن وقعت كرة البولنج
التي هي أنا في حقل الفلسفة
والذي أسميه أنا علم نفس الوجود
طبعًا أكو أشياء تضحك كلش وايه
أول مادخلت لعلم النفس
قالوا راح تطلع مجنونة
بس طلعت عاقلة شويا
بعدين لما دخلت فلسفة التقى بي
بروفسور بلبنان ببيروت
وقال احذري الفلسفة
لأن هناك من دخل الفلسفة ولم يعد إلى أهله
وأني هاليوم عدت إلى أهلي
ومن صناعة مفاجأت أن ماقلتلهم
أني جاية هنا أنا.
فبلشنا بدأنا نمزج بين الفلسفة وعلم النفس
وشلون ننزلها إلى الواقع
فشان الطريق الحقيقي مع خيال الشعر
أن يكون بهذه السفينة ينضم كل كائن
بغض النظر عن عرقه وعن دينه
فراحت الكتابة تنتقل
الآن أصبحت الكتب تترجم إلى اللغات
الأوربية واللغات الأجنبية الآخرى.
إذن الإنسان عنده هم مشترك واحد بلا عنصرية
كل هذه كانت رحلة بحث عن السعادة
السعادة هي الحكمة هي المعرفة
والمعرفة موعبارة عن واحد يقرأكتب وبس
لا، إذا أني ما أعرف صاحب الكتاب
هو يطبق هذه الأمثال وهذه المبادئ
أني إذًا ماقريت شيء
أني أريد أصيرأنا ولست هم
إذا صرت هم، إذًا أني ما ألي حق الإنتقاد
لهذا اختاريت أن أقول التمرد
لكن أنطي دليل جديد
فبدأ نشر السعادة وبالعمل التطوعي
وبالعمل الإنساني
حتى أقول لكم شنو معنى السعادة
وكم فيها أشياء بسيطة
آخر زيارة ألي في بغداد
قررت احتفل بعيد ميلاد أختي
مع مجموعة من الأصدقاء
بأحد تقاطعات المنصور مع الأطفال المشردين
كانت هاي النقطة الوحيدة اللي لحد الآن
أمشي بيها
وتعرفون الآن كل ما كان هناك نازحيين
هناك أطفال شوارع
جبنا الكيك المغطس بالشوكولا
وحطينا بيه شموع
وزعناه لهم
وبدأنا نغني
لكن المأساة أن هما ماعرفوا هالأغنية
ولاعرفوا يغنون
وأهم شيء عند الطفل هو
"الهابي بيرث داي تو يو"
خلص بدأنا نأكل
واحد من الأطفال جاء قال لي
أريد هالشيء الطويل اللي بيه خيط
أريد أكله خلصت
قلت له أنت أش سويت؟
ياسادة الطفل لم يعرف الشمعة
ياسادة الطفل أكل الشمعة
والشمعة نور
وبإيماني أن لكل مأساة
لها نهاية
وكل مشكلة لها احتمال حل
صرت وين ما أروح
أسوي عيد ميلادات بالشارع مع الأطفال
طبعًا ما مسموح لي أحط صور
لأنه فرحتهم كانت أكبر من الصور
لكن مؤمنة أن الشمعة راح تشعل من جديد
وبعد ماكو طفل يأكل شمعة
شكرًا